Joe: A Brit and an American swap countries
to try each other's Burger Kings.
This is "Food Wars."
So, obviously you can get a Whopper meal
at a UK and a US Burger King.
But we did want to get
them in both countries
and compare the two to
see the differences.
This here of course is
a standard Whopper meal.
I believe it was the regular size.
And this would be a small in the US.
Just a quick visual check,
I mean, the Whopper itself looks identical
to the Whopper that I'm
used to seeing in the UK.
Really, really no changes there.
The toppings seem to be the same.
You get the mayo, the pickles,
the lettuce, the tomato,
onions, and of course
the beef on a sesame bun.
So that's, yeah, exactly what I'm used to.
Let's take a look at a UK Whopper.
Looks exactly the same, so that's good.
Same size. Yeah, it's a big one, right?
Same stuff on the inside.
Oh, and I got a regular one.
I didn't even get it with
cheese, which is rare for me.
That tastes pretty similar
to what I'm used to.
The beef is pretty
similar, if not identical.
You still get that flame-grilled thing
that Burger King is kind of known for.
American mayo so far has
just been very creamy,
but pretty much everything
else is the same.
Overall, very similar to the
Whopper that I'm used to.
Exactly the same, which is
good. But the fries, however,
your fries are a bit different, I think.
Honestly, the fries, this
is a large Whopper meal.
I was kind of expecting
bigger for the US, you know?
There's a good portion of
fries, don't get me wrong.
But I feel like in the US,
if you order a large fries,
I was expecting, like, a lot of fries.
They look pretty similar to
the fries that I'm used to.
They're fairly thick-cut,
thicker-cut than, like, a McDonald's, so.
These are pretty good
fries, I have to say.
I feel like when I go to
a Burger King in the UK,
I'm not really there for the fries.
The fries are just very much
a sort of add-on to the meal.
These are good. These taste way better
than the fries that I'm
used to from Burger King.
I don't know what
they've done differently.
They're quite aggressively salted,
which I personally really like.
But they're just well cooked.
There's a little bit of
crisp on the outside.
Still quite nice and fluffy on the inside.
The US Burger King has —
the fries are weird.
There's some sort of batter to them.
I can't describe it. They
changed it years ago,
and they're a more distinct flavor.
I don't dislike them,
but they're not that great.
These regular fries, I think I prefer
the UK Burger King fries
over the US ones, definitely.
And of course, the fountain Coke.
I hope that the camera can capture
the scale of just how large this drink is.
I have a big head.
Yeah, I mean, it's
fountain Coke. It's fine.
Yeah, this regular drink is so tiny.
I've just been informed that a whopper
can be considered an insult
in the UK. What does it mean?
That's funny.
Have you been called a whopper before?
Someone called you a whopper?
I think generally
speaking, fairly familiar.
Pretty much what I'm used
to in terms of the burger.
I've enjoyed these fries
more than I enjoy the British fries.
And the Coke is too big.
Dial that back a little
bit, guys. Calm down.
Here's everything you
can get at a BK in the US
that you can't find in the UK.
Here are all the UK Burger King menu items
I cannot get in the US.
Let's take a look at
the US beef exclusives.
We'll start with this, the Whopper Jr.
Look at this thing. It's tiny!
I mean, yeah, I think it's
just a scaled-down version
of the Whopper. It's got all
the same toppings on there.
Now we're going from one end of the scale
straight to the other.
We're going from the junior
Whopper to the triple Whopper.
As the name suggests, it is a Whopper,
but instead of the one
patty, you get three.
I mean, I don't necessarily object
to the existence of a triple Whopper.
I will say I've got some
notes on the assembly,
because there's no layering going on.
Obviously a Whopper doesn't have cheese.
This is literally just the toppings
and then just three meat
patties back to back.
So I feel like when you bite into this,
you're just going to get a
big mouthful of just beef.
I mean, I will try it for science.
I'll take a little bite of the triple.
Yeah, that's kind of confirmed my fears.
I'm also covered in mayo.
Next up, we're off to Texas,
because this is a Texas Whopper.
In case you're wondering
what made this Texan,
it seems like they've just added
some jalapeños,
bacon, cheese,
and mustard
to a standard
Whopper.
I don't really know
enough about Texas culture
to know if that makes
something Texan or not.
I would've expected
maybe some barbecue sauce
if you call something Texan,
but they seem to have not
done that. So, we'll see.
I'm a big mustard fan,
so I like the inclusion
of mustard on this.
Yeah, that's not bad. I don't
know if I would order that
just over a standard Whopper,
but I think it's better
than a triple Whopper.
This is the BK double melt,
with a signature cheesy sauce
instead of a slab of cheese.
They just drizzled the, excuse
me, melted liquid cheese.
The melted cheese is kind
of a nice texture to it.
A slice of cheese would
just as easily suffice.
Bacon double cheeseburger XL, Charlie.
Two patties, cheese in the
middle, cheese in between them.
Very smart, guys. See?
It makes a difference.
It's bigger than — in America,
we have the regular bacon
double cheeseburger.
This one is a little bit bigger.
Well, it's extra bigger. So there you go.
Yeah, I like this.
And I would probably get this
if I went to Burger King.
I think this would do
really well in America.
Come on, two big beef patties,
dripping with cheese
and bacon. And it's big.
It's like, its selling
point is that it's big.
Dude, this would clean up in the US.
If this is in the US,
we gotta get US bacon.
Look at this. Come on, guys, look at this.
How, like, not pink this is.
This is like, oh, this bacon's bad.
Then we have two more burger exclusives,
which are the kings.
First up, we have the
Single Quarter Pound King.
This is a single quarter-pound patty
with some onions, pickles,
cheese, mustard, and ketchup.
This looks pretty good
to me. This looks like
a very classic hamburger,
which I'm kind of here for.
I will say, in general,
what I'm really enjoying
about all of these burgers is the pickles.
I feel like America does
pickles way better than we do.
I thought that was going
to be better than it was.
I don't know why. I don't
know what's wrong with it.
There's quite a lot of onion in it.
Just a lot of raw white onion.
And then the next one
I think we might have
had recently on the menu,
or it might still be
on the menu in the UK,
but is a bacon king.
Either way, I thought this
would be a good opportunity
to talk about fast-food bacon.
This is a double burger,
some cheese in the middle and on top,
along with a few rashers of
bacon, some ketchup, and mayo.
Let me just prize a bit of
this bacon off this burger
so we can get a closer look.
So, this is the famous
American fast-food bacon.
So, I feel like the US and
the UK do fast-food bacon,
and I guess bacon in
general, pretty differently.
This in the UK would be
called a streaky bacon rasher,
which is where you get
the kind of thin strips,
as opposed to back bacon,
where you have a medallion
and then some strip coming off it.
Generally speaking, in
the UK, fast-food bacon
tends to be quite a pallid
pink, fairly unappealing color,
and can be quite floppy as well.
They don't tend to cook it
basically for long enough.
I will say this bacon has
a lot more color on it
than I would expect to see
from British fast-food bacon.
That's pretty good. I think
that's probably better than
the bacon that I'm used to
from a British fast-food chain.
So far, all the bacon I've
had, including this one,
it just tends to have a better texture.
There's a bit more chew to it.
It's just been cooked a
little bit longer, I think.
Also, it lends itself to
giving it a much nicer color.
And you definitely get more
of a smoky flavor from it
that you would expect from good bacon,
which I don't think you tend
to get from UK fast-food bacon.
Yeah, the gourmet kings.
Let's go! Ooh! Fancy.
First one, farmhouse,
straight from the farm.
You got your rocket, aka arugula.
You got your ... pickled red onions?
And, like, a smoky cheddar cheese, right?
This is actually,
this is pretty impressive
looking, I gotta say.
Ooh, brioche bun.
Now here we go.
The arugula, or rocket, kind of ruins it.
I like it, but it's such a strong flavor,
it just really tastes like
arugula, rocket, whatever.
So having a bite without
it is a lot better.
So, unfortunately I think
the arugula's a little much.
This one also has arugula on it, so uh-oh.
Let's get a look in there, man.
They got the barbecue
sauce, crispy onions, right?
And the same cheddar, same fun cheddar.
The arugula's kind of still
a little overpowering,
but with the fun stuff, and
this cheese that's on here
is really good, the smoked cheddar.
This one's good. I would
get this. I like this.
So steakhouse over farmhouse.
Then we have a couple of very adorable
tiny burgers down at the end.
This one is the Rodeo burger.
So we're going back to
the South for this one.
To make this Rodeo, they've added
barbecue sauce and some onion rings.
See, the only reason I
can think of onion rings
counting as Rodeo is that
maybe it looks a little bit like a lasso.
Lasso.
No.
And then finally we just
have a double cheeseburger.
You guys got the Memphis barbecue burgers,
single and double. Go side by side.
You know, we, in the US, we got something
called the Rodeo burger. I
don't think you have that here.
Where it's onion rings and barbecue sauce,
and it's surprisingly good.
But it's, like, the smallest
thing. It's, like, that big.
But this is a good idea.
This is that, but adult size.
Yeah!
I gotta get a bite, but I gotta make sure
I get an onion ring in it, so.
This works really well together.
This all works. The creamy mayo,
the mayo and the barbecue sauce
and the onion rings, and the bacon?
Yeah, dude, this is good!
Another thing that would
do so well in the US.
I don't know why we don't have this
in the States, as you say.
I will say, they'd have to rename it.
It'd have to be, like, the Rodeo
burger deluxe or something.
I don't know what about this is Memphis.
I mean, the barbecue
sauce, it's a sweet sauce.
I don't know what makes it
"Memphis-y" specifically.
And I'm still not clear on
why onion rings equals Rodeo.
Then we're on to some chicken,
fish, and side options.
We'll start with these ones,
which are chicken fries.
Now, I'm pretty sure we can get these
or have had these in the UK before.
However, when we were recording this,
it seems as if the only ones available
are the Doritos chili heatwave version,
whereas these are the
old-fashioned classic ones.
These things are great. I love these.
I don't want to know how
they form the chicken
into long strips like this.
If British people are
familiar with Fridge Raiders,
the snacks, kind of like a bigger,
hotter version of those. It's great.
Next up we have a chicken sandwich option,
which is the chicken Jr.
As Joe just pointed out,
they love calling things
"Jr." at Burger King in the US.
Personally, I think they
should be called the prince.
You know? You have the
Burger King as the main one.
The little one should be a prince, surely.
Like a chicken duke,
or archbishop of beef.
It just looks like a very
simple chicken burger.
That's pretty good.
The mayo's quite creamy and quite sweet.
Chicken royale. Looks
just like the regular
original chicken sandwich we got at BK.
Longer, though.
Ah.
Oh, wait, but this one
has cheese and bacon.
Hm. Yeah, this looks kind of upsetting.
Kind of a bummer.
OK, crispy chicken Memphis style.
I do like the Memphis style.
Onion rings and bacon
and chicken with cheese?
That's a new combination right?
Yeah. Yeah to this. Yeah!
I think because it's fried chicken,
it adds even more flavor to it,
with the bacon, cheese, and onion rings.
It's a bit much, but it actually
works pretty well together.
I think we gotta Memphis up
some of our BK in the US.
Or just call it Rodeo-style it up.
Then we have a fish option, the big fish.
It's fairly reminiscent of a
Filet-O-Fish from McDonald's,
in that it's got that kind of shiny bun.
I do like a good fish sandwich.
Yeah, that's really not bad.
The fish is, like, fine.
It doesn't taste of a ton.
An acceptable attempt at a fish sandwich.
Probably not quite as
good as a Filet-O-Fish.
Then we have a side option
we can't find in the UK.
It's mozzarella sticks.
I feel like, yeah, we have now hit a point
where pretty much everywhere
does its own mozzarella stick.
What I will say is it
comes with a little thing
of marinara sauce, which
I think is the only
exclusive sauce at a US Burger King.
So we can do a very,
very short sauce talk.
Sauce talk.
The sauce is pretty strong, actually.
That's a concentrated tomato flavor.
It's almost like eating a tomato puree
rather than a marinara sauce.
Acceptable mozzarella sticks.
I probably wouldn't be
rushing toward those again.
Plant-based Whopper.
I'm pretty sure I did
this in the US, right?
But your guys' plant-based
meat is different than ours.
We have the Impossible meat in the US.
So, our Impossible
Whopper, Impossible meat
has a chemical that is under review.
You guys have a different
plant-based meat than we do.
So let's see what it tastes like.
It's not ... bad.
It's not flame-grilled-flavored enough,
you know what I mean?
Like, the Whopper, the
meat, you just taste
that grill smokiness, charcoaliness,
whatever you want to call it.
And this, it looks like
they cooked it the same way,
but I'm not getting that same
flavor from this meat at all.
So it still tastes like meat,
but it doesn't taste like a Whopper.
It doesn't have that
smoky flavor to it. So.
And I don't think that has
anything to do with the meat.
I think you guys have got
to flame grill it more
or add the same flame-grill
chemicals onto this
as you do the regular meat.
This is noticeably different
than the UK Whopper.
Vegan chicken.
Ew.
This looks exactly like the
original chicken sandwich, so.
There's something weird in here.
There's something weird to that flavor.
I'm just going to take a little —
Oh, this is not a good sign.
This meat is not easy to pull apart.
Ah! Ugh.
Nah, it just tastes weird.
It doesn't taste like chicken.
It tastes like it's
flavored like the chicken.
But the consistency of
it is just different.
I wouldn't say it was bad.
It just tastes like it's not chicken.
These came and went in the US so fast,
I didn't get a chance to try them.
But now I finally do.
Looks like a nugget.
Yeah, it just tastes like
a fake something or other.
Maybe the batter on this seems
thicker than regular nuggets,
so I'm getting almost all batter flavor,
which I guess isn't that big of a deal.
This doesn't taste like chicken.
Again, it's, like, blank.
It doesn't have much flavor to it.
Yeah, I mean, I think
you guys gotta step up
your chemical game, because our
fake meat tastes way better.
And these are chili cheese bites.
Actually, not that bad.
It's mostly — ooh, got a
little bit of heat to them too,
the jalapeños. Yeah, these are good.
On to the fries. Cheesy fries.
Oh, man, this is really phoned in.
This is really phoned
in. No effort on that.
Look at the bacon. It's not
crispy. It's, like, right?
This is the bacon they
have at an omelet station
to put in your omelet
pre-diced or whatever.
But this is like, guys,
it's gotta be crispy or nothing. Come on.
Nothing to it. It really
seems like a waste.
All right, sauce-talk time.
Got the sweet chili
and the smoky barbecue.
There's also a spicy mayo.
Wasn't available at the Burger
King we went to. Oh, well.
It' time for sauce talk,
"Foreign Exchange"!
Sauce talk.
The first one, sweet chili, boys.
Sweet chili is having a moment in the UK.
It's growing on me. I think
sweet chili's really nice.
Smoky barbecue.
Oh, this is a collaboration with
Bull's-Eye steak sauce, or barbecue sauce.
Was a big player in the sauce
game a decade or two ago.
But I feel like I haven't
seen Bull's-Eye in a while.
Mm, this is pretty good.
Here are all the US exclusive
breakfast items from Burger King.
We'll start on this
end, where we will find
breakfast biscuit sandwiches.
Now, if you saw the McDonald's episode,
you'll know that I didn't really like
their version of a breakfast biscuit.
This is the ham, egg, and cheese.
You can also get a bacon, egg, and cheese
or a sausage, egg, and cheese.
Now, I'm still not convinced
by the notion of a breakfast biscuit.
To the UK mind, this kind
of looks like a scone.
I will say this one kind
of feels a bit more buttery
and a bit more moist than
the McDonald's one did.
So maybe it won't be as bad.
It's hard to tell if this is
actually like a scone or not.
This has more of a sort of bready texture
than a scone does, for
the British audience.
I feel like a scone tends
to be a bit more crumbly
and doughy, whereas
this one is more bready.
As for the flavor,
there is a pretty similar
flavor, I would say,
in that the sort of main
taste you get is butter.
I don't know. It's pretty good.
Next up we've got the Croissan'wiches.
Now, for the uninitiated, like myself,
this is a breakfast sandwich,
but instead of a bun or a biscuit,
they use a cut-in-half croissant.
These come in the form of
bacon, egg, and cheese;
a sausage, egg, and cheese;
a ham, egg, and cheese;
or you can get a fully loaded option,
which comes with all of the above.
You get the bacon, you get the ham,
and you get the sausage patty.
Coming from a country that is
in pretty close proximity to France,
I feel like I do have to speak up
on behalf of my French friends out there.
Because, yeah, they just
look a bit sad, really.
I will say I kind of have more faith
in this idea than a biscuit.
Because at least a
croissant will be hopefully
flaky and buttery pastry
and not quite as dry as a biscuit will be.
I will say, there are
some places in the UK
that will do a ham and cheese croissant.
But it's usually a full-size
kind of crescent-shaped croissant,
which they would just cut in half
and then add the cheese, a
bit of ham, and then toast it.
These, I don't know.
It's the fact that they've
got the small circular ones.
So they've clearly been
purpose-built to be buns.
I'm not really sure about that.
I'll try the big boy.
I'll try the fully loaded Croissan'wich.
It's actually not the
worst delivery system,
because it is quite thin,
it is quite buttery,
and you do get a little bit
of the flakiness that you'd expect.
As much as I kind of
disagree with the concept
of a Croissan'wich, if you made me choose
between one of these
or a breakfast biscuit,
I do think I'm choosing these,
because it's closer to just a sandwich.
For all the Croissan'wiches,
you can also get a double-meat version.
So you can get double meat of the bacon,
of the sausage, and of the ham.
I don't think you can get a
double fully loaded version,
because that would just be kind of insane.
Then we have two
breakfast-burrito options.
We have the Egg-Normous Burrito
and the breakfast burrito Jr.
If this is Jr., then is this his dad?
My favorite thing to do is
just invent fast-food lore.
I'm not 100% sure what's
in either of these,
so let's find out.
Oh, wow. Some sausage.
[laughs] Oh, God. Oh, no.
Oh, God. Oh, oh, there's,
like, rice in it.
I mean, I've really made a mess of this.
I'm sorry, guys.
So, I'm seeing what looks
like half a sausage patty,
some egg, and what I think is rice.
Give it a quick try.
That's a reasonably
palatable breakfast burrito.
And then the big boy, the Egg-Normous.
All right, what do we got in here?
Bacon, quite a lot of rice.
I'm not seeing any sausage in this one.
I'm pretty sure it's just
egg, bacon, and rice.
Let's give it a quick try.
It's OK. So, to me, this
does taste a little bit
claggy and hard to chew its way through.
However, I'm told it's supposed
to come with a salsa verde,
which I think they've
forgotten to give me.
So, maybe if I had a salsa with it,
that would ease the
digestion a little bit.
Also, this is called
the Egg-Normous Burrito,
but it's really not very,
like, this is not enormous, guys.
Come on. If you're going
to call something enormous,
we're in America, I
want properly enormous.
And then finally we have
some French toast sticks.
What is Burger King US's beef with France?
They're really just going for France here.
So, I don't think I've ever
had French toast before.
It's not really a thing in the UK.
So, in the UK, we have
eggy bread, or egg bread,
which is whisked-up eggs.
But it's a savory thing, because we're not
putting vanilla and
cinnamon and stuff in it.
Harry: I will have
basically just egg in bread
that I will fry in a pan
and then maybe eat with some ketchup.
I'm being told I have to
try this with the syrup,
so let's give that a go.
British person tries French
toast for the first time.
I mean, it is pretty good.
Joe: Yeah, of course. It's French toast.
This is even more egregious than pancakes.
Because this is like a churro
that you then dip in syrup.
Somehow that's for breakfast.
Not convinced if that is
a breakfast food or not,
but it's very tasty.
One last thing to note is
that at a US Burger King,
you can actually buy
several burger options
before 10:30 a.m.
While they're still
serving the breakfast menu,
they will also make you a
Whopper and I think a bacon king.
I'm not really sure who wants
a Whopper at, like, 9 a.m.
There's obviously exclusive
Burger King breakfast menu items,
but since the pandemic,
a lot of Burger Kings
are still working on a reduced menu.
They're almost nowhere
to be found. We looked.
Apparently you're only
finding them in, like,
service-station locations.
So, we looked around.
Couldn't find a place
that served them. Sorry.
Here are some drinks that I
can't usually find in the UK.
We'll start with this one,
which is Hi-C fruit punch.
That's such a deeply unnatural color.
Joe: American drinks, baby!
High-fructose corn syrup, let's go.
My British palate has not adjusted
to American soft drinks yet,
because this thing is aggressively sweet.
This one's Dr Pepper. I can't remember
if this is on the UK
Burger King menu or not.
But, I mean, I like Dr Pepper in the UK.
Let's see if it's the same in the US.
OK, yeah, no, that's
actually pretty comparable.
Burger King in the US also
has some milkshake options.
This one is the Oreo cookie shake.
This comes highly endorsed by Joe.
Did you say this was your
favorite fast-food shake?
Joe: I would say, yeah,
one of my favorites, yeah.
One of his favorites.
Joe: One of the best ones, yeah.
High praise. Let's give it a try.
I mean, yeah, that's delicious.
That is so thick. The straw
almost isn't up to the task.
Yeah, that really does taste like Oreos,
like the filling of the Oreo.
And then if that's not
enough chocolate for you,
they also have a chocolate
Oreo cookie milkshake.
I mean, yeah, it's
basically the same as that
but I think just with chocolate ice cream
instead of vanilla ice cream as the base.
Yeah, I don't think you need
to mess with the formula.
Stick with the classic.
Stick with vanilla.
OK, for drinks, Burger Kings in the UK
also have tea and espresso,
and the one we went to
didn't have hot drinks.
And they also have various Capri Suns,
which they did have and we did
order and they forgot them.
Then we have some Burger King desserts
that we can't find in the UK.
We have two options. Firstly,
chocolate chip cookies.
Seems like these come in an order of two,
which have cemented themselves together.
They don't look brilliant. They're quite
hard on the outside.
[cookie banging on table]
Don't know if cookies are
supposed to make that noise.
Those are quite overbaked.
Then we have a slice of
Hershey's sundae pie.
I'm kind of intrigued by this.
It's come pretty highly recommended to me.
I like the packaging. This is quite fun.
Don't bite your nails, kids.
Makes it very hard to open
Hershey's sundae pies.
I really don't know what
to expect from this,
but I guess I'm just
going to get a scoop out
and see what happens.
Is it pastry on the bottom?
I can't really figure out what's going on.
There's, I think, like, a sort of cakey,
biscuit base type thing.
Yeah, that is very rich
but also very tasty.
If there was one menu
item that I could keep
and take back with me to the UK,
I don't actually know if it would be
a specific menu item, or
maybe more like an ingredient.
I think I would take the
bacon that you guys have
at a US Burger King and
take that back to the UK.
Because I feel like here it actually
adds something to a burger, in
terms of texture and flavor,
whereas in the UK it's just kind of there.
Like, you don't really notice it.
And if there's one menu
item that I would delete
from all possible Burger King menus,
I think it would be that triple Whopper.
I think it just really was
everything that is wrong
with American fast food in general.
It's just kind of excess
for the sake of excess.
You don't need that much meat.
You need some kind of
lubrication in there.
It's just dry, chewy,
horrible. Get rid of it.
Harry: So, Joe, you've tried
all of our Burger King menu items.
Which one are you taking
back with you to the US?
I think I like the Memphis
barbecue burgers the best,
because it was like a Rodeo burger
but it's bigger and it
had more stuff on it.
So I think I could really get into that.
Harry: Then you can knock one
thing off the UK menu forever.
What's going?
What was it? Oh, that fake chicken.
The chicken royale specifically.
It was the consistency of
the chicken, how it tasted.
It just tasted off. It
tasted really weird.
Like, my body was like, "Do
not swallow. Spit out now."
So I feel like as a nugget
version, it would work.
But as the chicken royale,
didn't work. It's gotta go.